or dressing a college student that's
been stuck writing a thesis paper in
their dorm that doesn't have air
conditioning no hi my name is very
somebody no no no you know your life is
different now look at us or in the
kitchen which means one thing we're
gonna take things and put them together
make them hot and put them in this
little gas chambers literally I've been
very bloated lately I just took a SIBO
test last week the results are still out
can't wait to find out in the meantime
let's put some stuff in our body Elliot
it's been out of town since last week
and I've been eating like an actual
college student been eating solely chips
popcorn ice cream and dry cereal with my
hands I'm basically been eating like a
child whose parents like went on a
cruise and left them behind because
they're at the age where they can take
care of themselves but really that's all
they eat but today I thought I deserve
to eat like an adult which means a meal
that has protein which means just a meal
Cala fresh yeah you probably know this
by now I'm also doing dry January which
means I'm not drinking it'll be a little
bit of a different cooking video it's
still gonna be fun I would think not
drinking have the ability to make this
meal perfectly and you know what there's
no way of knowing what's gonna happen
dry January is boring I'm gonna be I'm
gonna be honest I January is basically
filling up your schedule with activities
until you get to February and this is
one of them I also spent an entire day
watching the circle on Netflix Oh circle
gets a square circle gets this square
that show gets me if you have watched it
then you know that this meal is very
appropriate based on some of the little
gems that were in that show today we're
making old and beefy tacos
hashtag tacos all day every day however
I decided I wanna be a little bit
healthier so instead of using the beef
that comes with this recipe I'm gonna
use ground turkey look at me making
adult decisions let me drink my water I
mean my content is now for children
we're gonna have fun guys know I've been
working with hella fresh forever if you
didn't know don't care I got a bathroom
to paint after this so we got big plans
today you guys Oh talking points here we
go
ready buddy
ballerina that can't shut up a talking
point have I made that joke already I
also realized that I have very short
term memory I always blamed it on
drinking and guess what it's not the
drinking it's my brain do you want to
break out of your cooking rat well now
you can with hellofresh is 22 plus
seasonal chef curated recipes that they
offer each week I'm doing these talking
points like just your your college bud
that's having a candid conversation with
you unlike that sketchy uber driver that
took you home from the frat party last
night
how old fresh is more five-star ratings
than any other meal kit out there are
you going to study hall today I don't
study home in college hey Paul is trying
I know you have trouble with time
management but guess what hellofresh can
save you time did you know that the
average grocery store visit takes about
41 minutes
that's over 35 hours a year if you go
one so we take those hours and get
Hillel first delivered to you now you
can spend more time searching for poun
on the campus unlike your incoming
freshman body weight how little fresh is
all about sustainability
I see those elastic waistbands
hellofresh comes with pre portion
ingredients that's what hello fresh
comes with pre portion ingredients that
means there's less prep for you and less
food waste because you know the only
thing we want to waste is our potential
student loans and just like that girl
down the hall that's majoring in dance
because I guess you can do that in
college tella fresh is flexible you can
change up your delivery days you can
skip a week you can change your meal
preferences and just like you and that
girl down the hall did that one night
after that thing you can experiment ok
enough talking about college and getting
like anxiety flashbacks let's do it look
at all of it you lying by while I'm
making some hellofresh meals but it's
dry January so that doesn't mean you
don't have to though we're gonna
maintain the built-in drinking game
there's six steps here right now decide
which step you think I might memorably
cup and if I do drink if I don't drink
make your own rules live your own life
have the most fun I wanted to make these
tacos because I feel like this is a
recipe that you can kind of mix and
change and do whatever the [ __ ] you want
with like your identity all throughout
your college years first things first
wash and dry all produce path peel and
finely dice this onion I
probably the most representative of how
I was in college they have a lot of
layers but it's insanely difficult for
anyone to peel away it makes me cry a
lot I did get SIBO testy I'm one of the
major things that you shouldn't have if
you have SIBO our onions and garlic but
just like college this might make my
stomach hurt
finally dice our tomato tomatoes are
like children
I just complained and slimy and gross
but they're also like really popular
good enough finely chopped cilantro
leaves the fun thing is because I'm not
drinking I really supplement it with a
lot of caffeine know if I'm shaking it's
because my blood is like good 70% Red
Bull just like college I'm gonna zest in
quarter the lime zest ring means that
you basically give the lime a good shave
woo cute it is like shaving the line but
it's gross because then you're gonna
keep all of basically the lime hair
clippings and put it in your food to eat
in your body
I didn't major in like appropriate
metaphor water what you need for laundry
in college or misstep - hey you know
what that means
thank you water I love treating my body
like a goddamn temple it is so fun and
fulfilling and rewarding we're gonna
make the slaw now medium bowl yes like
my college experience you're a solid
medium Wow we need to squeeze three lime
wedges into this bowl ow ow ow ow I have
tiny cuts all around my fingertips
because I bite my nails and sometimes I
bite the skin around it do I have a
problem with anxiety and nervousness no
I treat my body creatively at a drizzle
of olive oil at a teaspoon of sugar I
don't have sugar which is ironic because
all my body wants right now is sugar but
I have Splenda I don't care if you think
this is gross much of what I do in my
house is very gross let me live Glenda
oh they add coleslaw and season with
salt and pepper I'm using my teeth
you'll probably learn from some
douchebags not to use your teeth slaw
goes in so damn pepper we toss it to
coat and we set this aside we're done
step 2 damn it step 3 we're gonna make
the guacamole and the pico de gallo my
neighbors just got home so I'm gonna
close my blinds this is awesome what I
did in my dorm in college and I heard my
roommate get home I guess what I'm
sleeping okay I'm gonna combine the
guacamole beautiful and the sour
okay we're gonna put half of our tomato
in here half of the cilantro and a pinch
of the onion and we season with salt and
pepper and then we stir to combine does
look like something that you just throw
up into a bush before you got into an
uber after a frat party out of respect
we need another bowl like every college
student you know your way around the
bowl but combine the rest of the tomato
and cilantro we're gonna put some lime
zest in here and juice from the
remaining line out and a little bit of
the remaining onion and we season with
salt and pepper and look like that we
got pico de gallo already this is so
impressive now we're on the step four
you know what that means
we're having fun okay we're gonna cook
the beef and onion aka we're gonna cook
our ground turkey and onions we've got a
medium-sized pan on medium heat we're
gonna put some olive oil in there we're
gonna add our turkey and the remaining
onion maybe not as much not trying to
immediately shake hands after eating
this if I have SIBO we're gonna cook
until the turkeys cook through about
five to seven minutes which is if you're
really lucky how long a guy will last in
college and while that cooks I'm gonna
get to know you more I'm gonna do what I
didn't do in college or to socialize
actually I'm gonna do what I did in
college I'm gonna just turn you up and
come back when I have something to show
or contribute or say or okay I'm back
I'm young I'm fun here we go our turkey
and onion is basically now cooking and
we're gonna transfer that to a paper
towel-lined plate that means we're on to
step 5 oh look at this I'm getting lit
step 5 we're gonna make our filling in
the same pan that the turkey was just in
and this tex-mex paste and 1/4 cup of
water and then stir to combine it's kind
of like my breast size in college it was
like 1/4 of a cup unlike anything ever
said to any of the guys I dated in
college this smells skin great every
with the turkey and onion back into the
pan and we heat for about two to three
minutes and season with salt and pepper
hey friends that looks so edible okay
what's what's going on what am i doing
can't handle it really takes the edge
off our turkey has been cooked we take
it off the heat and that means we
finished at five whoa I got
pace myself we're on to the final step
Wow when you're not drinking you get
things done very efficiently do you have
as much fun yes
petition served last step as we take our
tortillas he amidst with consent so
we're supposed to you know not all tacos
look the same but it doesn't mean
they're not all delicious in the road
right no some of them have weird Falls
and weird beds and it just adds to the
character in the charm we're gonna wrap
the tortillas in a damp paper towel put
them in the microwave for 30 seconds so
now we're going to divide the Cherokee
and then just add all the fixes
this is what the group of girls look
like when they show up at the toga party
and then this is what they look like
trying to find their Eber on the way
home when they lost one of their friends
and they looked for her for like a
little bit of time but then they didn't
give us any more because she's actually
super annoying to them and they know
that like she can find our way home and
yet maybe her phone's dead but like you
know it's natural selection at this
point perserving finance majors out
there do the math literally do it I
think you probably have to do it to get
a degree you guys can get a deal on
hellofresh they're having a New Year's
sale if you go to hellofresh calm and
use the promo code grace helbig 10 you
can get 10 free meals and free shipping
again go to kill afresh calm use promo
code grace helbig 10 10 free meals free
shipping if you were in college 10 free
meals is like a month's worth of meals
or like a day's worth of meals I don't
there's a lot of different types of
college appetites I'm gonna do something
I didn't do in college I'm gonna taste a
taco I can't believe how the fresh lets
me promote their brand oh I've done that
some calls true great that was delicious
I am so sober so I can like do others
look at me grow here watching let me
know if you make this and if you're
making any hellofresh meals I know some
of you treat up me and show me the meals
that you're making and they look
delicious subscribe to this YouTube
channel I'm making videos you know
whatever other than that I don't know I
don't know why we're going with a
college team but we are I feel like
tacos are like something you can make as
a college student that's like a level up
from ordering pizza oh you guys have
post mates now I don't have post mates
in college you know it's spoiled
enjoy this free content enjoy your post
mates and all the other amazing
technological advances that make your
life so much easier
you know my campus had skunks for some
reason lots of them and not like the
kind like the kind